people are calling you an interest
industry plant you're not the only one
so um and they think that because like
where did this girl come from I mean
sure she had great mom content for a
while but like where's she getting all
these big celebrities and here you are
blowing up you were on Good Morning
America today
what was it today show yes the Today
show I keep getting them confused
um I
I've done them all okay um and to me I
don't know which is which I just know
it's morning television yeah oh heck is
it fun to do something like that
were you nervous
I was why because it's live uh yes could
you tell me like what was that
experience like
I don't feel like you're this is this is
real I'm being sincere now like I it's
really cool to do that stuff and this is
your first time on television yes and
your first number television is live
television
yes I mean that's nerve-wracking
uh-huh